so leute pepo fett ich sag euch massive pepo fett
fetteste pepo aller zeiten ich bin richtig voll gefressen
ich habe eine sushi platte bestellt für drei personen wir waren nur zwei personen aber ich
habe für drei personen bestellt und habe im prinzip keine ahnung irgendwie 60 prozent oder so
davon gefuttert all da bin ich voll danach habe ich noch zwei kleine bratappel gessen
also die waren wirklich klein mit eis dabei und jetzt habe ich noch ein bisschen schokoladen
kram hinten drauf gefuttert leute ich bin so krass voll gefressen das kann ihr euch nicht
vorstellen super krass pepo fett heute also wirklich hyper pepo fett anders kann ich nicht
beschreiben daniel lull 30 monate huge subscription ja dankeschön
dazu kann ich nur sagen massive ich bin zu voll gefressen dass ich meine subscription
emotes finde wo sind meine subscription emotes oi leute gibts heute rust ja ich roste an
höchstens weil ich mich nicht mehr bewege das machen wir heute nicht wirklich heute
machen wir gar nichts außer ein bisschen pepo fett sein und schwätzen
denn was will ich das genauer wissen wahrscheinlich nicht
ja würde ich euch auch allen leute ich hänge hier halb unterm tisch und bin so voll gefressen
dass ich mich noch mal bewegen kann zu pepo fett to move das ist ein gutes command ja
zu dick zum bewegen für den stream na gut zum stream muss ich mich ja auch nicht bewegen
das ist doch ganz klar meinte ich bewege mich hierbei gerade ne das geht nicht aber ich
muss jetzt ihr hört schon kaputt ein bisschen mehr geschwätzt weil weihnachten und zeugs
haben leute angerufen und ihr wisst andere menschen gehen mir auf den sack aber ich muss
mit denen reden deswegen tut mir der hals ein bisschen mehr weh und deswegen wenn ich jetzt
noch ein zucker aber zucker freies leute zucker freies hals bonbon zucker frei für extra frischen
atem werde ich jetzt futtern also futtern lutschen da chi base erst mal kacken und twitch
gucken das eine sehr gute idee das ist prinzipiell also kacken und twitch gucken ist prinzipiell
immer eigentlich eine gute idee massive pepo fett ja aber es gibt sonst so spannendes
im hintergrund ist übrigens die overwatch musik vom winter event aber die wiederholt
sich gefühlt schon zum 200 mal ich glaube man muss gleich was anderes anmachen ja wie
gesagt ich habe euch auf twitch gepostet ich habe auf twitter gepostet was ich gefuttert
habe warum sind eigentlich alle seiten heutzutage so nervig hartnäckig mit bitte subscrib doch
subscrib doch jetzt endlich mal falls du es noch nicht wusstest du kannst jetzt auch
subscriben übrigens ist es möglich zu subscriben ich weiß nicht ob ich dir das schon gesagt
habe seite du kannst jetzt den leuten auch followen follow doch mal den leuten alter ist
das nervig also ihr könnt also es ist ja schon ein drittel weg so das ist eine platte gewesen
für drei personen und ich habe ungefähr naja wenn ihr die seite hier mal weglasst
habe ich ungefähr das gefressen was noch da ist ohne diese seite ehrlich ganz die tunfisch
tunfisch habe ich nicht gegessen die zwei tunfisch ist nicht so meins dafür mag ich
die lachsdinger ne für zwei personen und aber die platte ist für drei personen pinterest
hat angefangen ja aber ich habe seit ich gucke auch nie auf pinterest instagram ist jetzt
auch so wenn du auf instagram einfach nur ein foto aufmachen willst von irgendwas ja sagt
ist das auch guck mal hier ich sehe du hast das foto aufgemacht willst du dich nicht gleich
anmelden so ätzend es gibt für die meisten user die platte sieht nicht nach drei personen
aus naja guck mal hier das sind insgesamt 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 so inside out rolls 8 so solcher
dinger 8 solcher dinger 8 solcher dinger und 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 und 18 solcher dinger also
leute ich fress schon viel aber ich habe es nicht geschafft weg zu futtern und dass wir
haben dass die platte ist für drei personen für zwei personen gegessen und ich habe schon
viel gefuttert und ich bin mega voll aber ich kann euch sagen war wirklich nice ihr
macht das alleine weg ja ok leute ihr seid noch ihr macht das ihr seid noch krasser drauf
als ich was essen angehe ich sehe schon chat weiß es wieder besser aber das hat wirklich
mal gut geschmeckt ich habe schon ganz lange kein sushi mehr gefuttert und ich habe auch
erst vor nicht all zu langer zeit gelernt dass man diese sorte sushi dinger gar nicht
in die soja soße taucht sondern nur die obere seite in die soja soße taucht ich habe das
immer falsch gemacht ich habe das ding genommen habe das an das seid in die soja soße getunkt
und schnell wieder rausgezogen das problem ist dass hier von die hälfte abfällt wenn
es in die soja soße tungst wenn du das einfach nur oben rein tungst das nur oben soja soße
dran ist dann ist das viel besser das habe ich ohne scheiß vor einem youtube video gelernt
wo die leute bei jedem japanischen sushi meister sushi futtern waren und die haben dann den
erst mal erklärt dass sie das falsch machen daher weiß ich das da soll mal einer sagen
man lernt bei youtube nichts sushi all you can eat habe ich auch schon lange nicht mehr
gemacht naja was noch mal erklären was denn ja das hätte ich auch gegessen ja wie gesagt
und wobei ich sagen muss ich habe so lange kein sushi zeug mehr gegessen das war echt
mal wieder nice fällt mir gerade was ein ich war mal in frankfurt auch sushi sushi das
war zu mittagessen damals zu mittagessen sushi futtern in frankfurt und das ist ja oftmals
auch ähnlich wie hier dass dann so ein bisschen von diesem scharfen zeug wie heißt es noch
mal wasabi dass man so ein bisschen verziert wasabi neben dran hat und da haben wir so
eine kleine vierer packung bestellt da war auch so ein verziertes wasabi dabei und der
typ auf der arbeit der hat diese vierer packung gefuttert gemeint so ich bin fertig und dann
wollte das quasi wegschmeißen und hat gesehen ach da ist ja noch so ein karotten ding drin
und das karotten ding genommen hat sich dann komplett im mund geschmissen und hat den
fehler gemacht auch noch luft zu holen dabei der war auf einmal irgendwie nicht mehr so
gesprächig aber das gute das gute an wasabi ist das brennt nicht so krass wie der wusste
das nicht dem war das nicht klar dass das so scharf ist aber das ist ja nicht scharf
im sinne von von schilly oder sowas schilly ist ja so dass das fängt an zu brennen und
brennt dann immer mehr und das brennt dann auch zehn minuten noch und am anderen tag
brennt noch beim kacken wasabi ist eigentlich nur mal ganz kurz richtig brutal gerade wenn
du gerade wenn du wenn du luft holst aber danach ist eigentlich wieder weg
so wie senf ja so ein bisschen also wasabi ist ja aus mehrrettig mehrrettig ist halt
auch so das ist so weißes zeug normalerweise was man also es ist glaube ich nicht dieser
standard weiße mehrrettig den man bei uns aber es ist auch so eine mehrrettig sorte
ist das ja oder eher mehrrettig abkömmling und das ist halt ein bisschen scharf aber
halt nicht aber nicht schilly scharf ja nichts spannendes die sache ist die es ist unglaublich
schwierig sich sachen zu schenken oder sich schenken zu lassen ab einem gewissen alter
weil ich meine wenn ich jetzt der meinung bin keine ahnung ich brauch jetzt einen neun
dreißig zoll bildschirm da kaufe ich mal einen neun dreißig zoll bildschirm oder wenn
ich denke ich brauche jetzt eine neue konsole dann kaufe ich mal eine neue konsole dann
muss ich halt auf weihnachten warten ich weiß noch früher wo ich klein war da musste ich
dann für den n64 habe ich echt irgendwie keine ahnung ein dreiviertel jahr meine mutter
meinen vater mein opa meine oma die habe ich alle bearbeitet da schon n64 krieg kennt
ihr noch das n64 kit nintendo 64 die da so ungefähr habe ich mich damals auch gefreut
so habe ich mich dann wahrscheinlich auch darüber gefreut
damals war das was super mega krasses heute ist man an so technik schon schon fast gewöhnt
ja psp ok ja psp war auch nass ich habe immer noch keine ahnung wie ist sony nach der psp
mit mit der vita so extrem verkacken konnte die vita war ja technisch nicht schlecht aber
die hatten nix und haben selbst nicht richtig supportet ich meine psp war nie von der popularität
her so was also von den verkaufszahlen weiß ich nicht aber denke ich auch nicht aber sag
man so gameboy und so ist ist jedem auch jeden eltern damals ein begriff gewesen psp nicht
wirklich ja nur wenn die kinder gesagt haben ich will eine psp haben ja die haben die haben
keine gescheiten games und was sony bei der vita auch gemacht haben ist ja die haben jahre
lang immer erzählt auch wir sind voll committed auf die vita aber zeigen euch heute keine
vita spiele nächstes jahr wir sind voll krass committed auf die vita immer noch keine
vita spiele gezeigt ja ja dafür ist sie gut und mal ohne scheiß wisst ihr woran man sieht
dass es wirklich wirklich gute hardware war wenn die heute noch wunderbar sich zum emulieren
eignet also sie muss ja für die und die ist ja auch schon die die ist ja auch schon irgendwie
acht jahre alt oder so die ps vita ich weiß gar nicht wann die ursprünglich raus kam
ist auch schon ganze weile her aber hier ja zehn jahre ist das ding ich habe noch eine
rumliegen hier aber was habe heute ein video gesehen wo ein kind sich nicht über eine
ps5 gebräuchert zurückbringt er will ja ein pc so ist richtig das finde ich gut der fängt
in jungen jahren schon mit der richtigen sache an pc master race da kannst du da kannst
du nicht früh genug anfangen pizze master race ist einfach so scheiß wixbox und gay
station pc master race alter ich weiß nicht was hat man damals als beleidigung für playstation
gesagt gay station darf man heute bestimmt nicht sagen das ist ja schon grenzwertig
homophob und triggert wieder leute aber wixbox ist ok was was ist denn eine eine zeitgemäße
playstation beleidigung mir fällt keiner ein ohne scheiß das wird mich auch mal interessieren
ganz ehrlich du kannst von den eltern oder opa und oma noch schlimmer nicht erwarten
dass du noch durchblickst dass du jetzt aktuell eine xbox series x kaufen muss und keine xbox
360 keine xbox one s keine xbox series s keine one xbox one x oder was es sonst noch alles
gibt da kannst du da kannst du wirklich nicht erwarten dass da das dir schwenken das kannst
du wirklich erwarten dass da einen durchblickt es ist ja noch schlimmer damals als die wiu
rausgekommen ist da haben die leute ja damals schon zu nintendo gesagt leute ich check das
jetzt nicht es ist jetzt ein addon für die wii oder was ist das oder hat musste nintendo
immer wieder erklären nein nein das ist eine neue eigenständige konsole aber so ignorant
wie nintendo halt ist haben die das dann auch nicht mehr ordentlich benannt da haben sicherlich
auch viele das falsche gekauft du musst immer davon ausgehen die normalen user die einkaufen
und die normalen leute sind einfach nubs nicht einfach nur nubs das sind die dümmsten nubs
die du dir vorstellen kannst und auf die musst du das auslegen dass die das verstehen man
kann es nicht einfach auf den high IQ auf den high IQ twitch chats hier irgendwie auslegen
das ist nicht die realität irgendwer ist immer gedriggert ja und wenn wenn nur sind die leute
gedriggert weil leute gedriggert sind ja richtig pepo fett leute ich bewege mich keinen zentimeter
wenn ihr sehen könnt wie ich da hänge ok doch jetzt muss ich mal bewegen weil ich merke
gerade als wenn ich so weiter also wenn ich weiter so liegen bleiben würde würde meine
linke poppersbacke einschlafen deswegen muss ich jetzt mal kurz aufstehen mich mal auf
die andere seite setzen alle ich habe mich so heftig auf meinen stuhl blumen lassen wenn
es ein billiger stuhl wäre wenn jetzt die federung kaputt aber ich habe jetzt zum glück
mein premium high IQ stuhl leute was meint ihr 2022 wird es jetzt endlich das jahr des
linux desktops werden ich glaube ja schon aber ich glaube wenn dann wegen wsl und wslg
und ich wegen wirklich linux auf dem desktop genau das denke ich genau das denke ich auch
wenn schon wegen wsl und wslg nicht nicht weil die irgendwas geschissen bekommen wie
geht es dir heute so ich bin sehr voll gefressen um nicht zu sagen kurz vorm platzen ich werde
mal kurz die musik wechseln das overwatch film müssen wir uns sonst nicht die ganze
seite anhören und das nächste die nächste frage ok ok dann haben wir jetzt beantwortet
dass 2022 wahrscheinlich auch nicht das jahr des linux desktops wird aber nächste frage
weil das ist die voraussetzung dafür wahrscheinlich dass es das jahr des linux desktops wird
2022 das jahr werden in dem alle auf windows 11 upgraden was meinen wir das machen wir
meistens silvester und dieses jahr wahrscheinlich auch nicht dieses jahr zu silvester werde
ich chicken burger bestellen du hast schon geupgraded ok binio meint microsoft wird uns
passiv dazu zwingen wie sollen die das machen das einzige was mir einfällt ist so geschichten
wie neue direct x version nur für windows 11 oder irgendwelche coolen features die microsoft
da irgendwie nicht hin bekommt das wüsste ich nicht wie sie da uns großartig zwingen
es gibt keine sicherheits updates mehr nee das können sie nicht einfach machen das werden
die auch nicht machen ich glaube wenn aus wenn aus 10 geht bis wann 2025 oder noch länger
2025 also das werden da werden die sich auch wirklich dran halten weil die haben so lange
jetzt gebraucht um so halbwegs das vertrauen in sowas wieder herzustellen da wären die
als mein ausgeschlossen ist nichts aber da wären extrem dumm wenn die das nicht nicht
machen würden und sagen hey leute ab nächstem jahr nur noch update zu windows 11 das glaube
ich nicht und mal ganz davon abgesehen ich ich hoffe ja noch ein bisschen drauf dass
windows 11 mit den updates ein bisschen besser wieder für meine zwecke zu benutzen wird
weil mich nervt zum beispiel extrem dass wenn aus elf die tabs immer standardmäßig
gruppiert hat anstatt dass ich hier meine programme in unterschiedlichen wie kommt man
überhaupt so eine bescheuerte idee ich meine überlegt mal die leute haben heutzutage ultra
hyper white screen und dann erordnet man es nicht nebeneinander an das ist total undurchdacht
aber gut wenn aus elf hat es ja alles auch keine rolle gespielt wichtig wichtig ist ja
wie viel ist heute also das emotionale könnt ihr euch noch an diese windows elf präsentation
erinnern wo die wo die eine erzählt hat so nach dem motto ja wenn ich zurück an meinen
vater denke dann denke ich dran wie wir an den windows pc sachen gemacht haben und und
das war so voll auf tränen trüsten emotional gemacht sollte man nicht im betriebssystem
kaufen oder betriebs der update machen weil man technisch überzeugt ist immerhin was
sie jucken mich irgendwelche emotionen wenn es mir jeden tag auf den sack geht das sind
dann eher negative emotionen man sind auch emotionen aber ich verbinde mit windows mit
windows elf sicherlich jetzt nicht hat ich eine geile kindheit mit windows ja mein vater
habe ich windows installiert weil der rechner immer abgekackt ist oder sowas nächste schwachsache
weiß ich was microsoft sich da denkt wahrscheinlich kommt e windows 12 noch bevor windows 10 ausläuft
oder die passion windows elf endlich so dass die meisten leute verwenden wollen jeder plus
grün ist doch jetzt gar nicht mehr blu oder war der plus grün art der plus grün jetzt
nicht nur warte mal ja genau das war doch jetzt das doch jetzt schwarz was plus grün
wieder blau mittlerweile ist das schon wieder blau ok keine ahnung ich dachte der der neue
plus grün oder windows elf ist jetzt schwarz aber ich habe windows elf noch nie live auf
dem rechner gehabt außer in der vm zum ausprobieren und ich glaube als wir das gecrasht haben
könnt ihr euch noch dran erinnern wir haben windows elf doch gecrasht in der vm hat sein
black screen oder so plus grüne ich weiß es nicht mal keine ahnung windows elf update
plus grün kehrt zurück krasser scheiß jawoll microsoft hat es geschafft das eines der aushängeschilder
und und top features von windows ist wieder dabei endlich plus grün leute erzählt mal
was gab es denn bei euch so zu futtern heute also bei mir gab es das hier sushi platte für
drei personen für zwei personen
käse suppe mit flanbrot das ist aber sehr minimalistisch ja sonny rp ich auch das verbinde
klopse aha bratwürst mit sauerkraut ente mit oh das ist nice das ist pock ich habe
vor ein paar tagen was ähnliches gegessen ich habe vor ein paar tagen zweieinhalb stunden
wandern habe ich gedacht ey komm lass mal danach was ordentliches futtern gehen und
da war ich im restaurant hier in der nähe und habe ganz mit knödel und rotkraut gefuttert
das war richtig exzellent hier exquisite und das war das erste mal als ich ins restaurant
gegangen bin dass ich irgendwie coronanachweise zeigen musste da kommt die an tisch und meint
so ja corona aus coronanachweis haben sie dabei habe ich gesagt ja ich habe hier einen
qr code zum scannen dann meint die aber ich habe keinen qr code scanner das geht ja schon
gut los oder habe ich gesagt ich habe meinen impfausweis fotografiert ob ihr das reicht
da meinte so ja hier reicht die hat noch nicht mal richtig drauf geguckt geschweige denn
das ist mein impfausweis war hat die auch nicht kontrolliert wie willst du das auf dem foto
aufmachen ja naja aber das ist das im endeffekt was ich gesagt habe so gastronomiebetriebe
haben wir da gar kein großes wirklich eigeninteresse daran das zu kontrollieren die machen das
mindeste dass sie nicht dicht gemacht werden wachs ich gucke deine video seit mehr als
zehn jahren damals und jetzt auf twitter deshalb pro wei noch danke für den content ja pock
dass dein weich her gefunden hast falls du wieder abhaust vielleicht sehen wir dich
ja demnächst wieder ich bin so voll gefressen leute ich merke es immer mehr kennen ihr das
am anfang seid ihr einfach nur voll aber wenn ihr es dann anfangen zu verdauen dann
werdet ihr gefühlt ihr euch noch voller richtig hart heute first world problems fresskoma
ja also richtig ist so richtig ist fresskoma kenne ich eigentlich nur von der arbeit aber
das kennt wahrscheinlich auch jeder wenn man wenn man mittagessen geht und dann wirklich
auch ordentlich was was was was was bisschen schwereres ist ja jetzt nicht vielleicht
einfach nur salat oder so ganz normales mittagessen halt ein bisschen was heftigeres deftigeres
ja schweres dann sitzt er dann zwei stunden vorm rechnen und die fallen fast die augen
zu das wird dann erst wieder besser wenn du weißt alle ich kann in einer halben stunde
heim und ich laufe dann erst mal zum südbahnhof dann bin ich eh wieder wach also ich esse
manchmal tatsächlich salat weil wir haben eine kantine und die haben ab und zu mal so
special mich wie sich das nennt so special es ist kein klassischer salat es ist es ist
so ein so ein topf da ist dann auch ein bisschen fisch zeug drin manchmal noch und und anderes
zeug und halt salat so ein topf ist das keine ahnung wie die das nennen aber das schmeckt
wirklich ganz gut immer nach dem asia buffet sushi sehen mega nice aus ja richtig pock
deswegen bin ich jetzt auch so voll gefuttert nee ich trinke ich also erstens ich trinke
kein kaffee oder nur sehr selten und es hilft mir auch nicht ich werde von kaffee ich weiß
nicht ob jemand das gefühl kennt aber ich werde von kaffee nicht wach ich werde von
kaffee zwar unruhig aber nicht weniger müde deswegen kaffee bringt mir gar nichts deswegen
trinke ich auch kein kaffee ich werde nur unruhig aber nicht wach ja das gibts ja kommt
vor ja leute jetzt ruhe ich grad von ähm von fresskoma auf der arbeit wo wir es grad
davon hatten ja was schlägst du denn vor fortnite cs ne hab ich nicht mal mehr installiert
was wollte ich jetzt sagen also an games installiert aktuell habe ich halo infinite immer noch
battlefield 2042 wieder battlefield 3 und ein paar nicht multiplayer games diablo 2 nee
ich spiele jetzt nichts ich bin viel zu voll ich kann leute ich kann nichts machen außer
da zu hängen vom rechner und mich nicht zu bewegen ja
erste bin ich nicht der einzige hab mir eben dein youtube video vom hauptbahnhof frankfurt
angesehen laufe auch tatsächlich stört das nicht mal äh was welches video ich hab ich
ich mach seit über 10 jahren youtube ich weiß jetzt nicht spontan ach du meinst fertige
leute am hauptbahnhof oder wie das hieß das kenne ich das spielt ja lost öfters das sieht
so ein bisschen aus wie pupke also grafisch hat es fast so hat es nicht sogar den gleichen
font die gleiche schriftart sogar wie pupke sieht aus wie pupke bloß mit irgendwie ein
bisschen apex fähigkeiten dabei sieht vom grafikstil und vom so artstyle sehr langweilig
aus finde ich ja ich also ich weiß nicht mehr was ich dort in dem video gesagt habe
ich weiß nicht was ihn nicht stört und was noch wie aber ja am hauptbahnhof in frankfurt
sind sehr viele fertige leute also deswegen hat es mich wahrscheinlich in berlin gar
nicht so geschockt ich weiß noch als wir auf das berlin auf das battlefield 1 event
in berlin gefahren sind das war das erste mal als ich in berlin war ich bin rausgekommen
aus dem bahnhof und es hat mich erstmal in obdachlose angehustet und ich habe mich gleich
wieder heim gefühlt das ist ja wie in frankfurt nur der ausblick ist ein bisschen besser
wenn du berlin am hauptbahnhof rauskommt da kannst du über so eine so eine parkanlage
gucken auf der einen seite nee nee das war es battlefield 1 reveal das war dann war ein
battlefield 1 reveal 2015 oder so das ist schon ein bisschen her was soll denn das sein
ah ein playstation controller und deutschland trikot stimmt fifa stimmt fifa ach nee smash
smash ich hätte gedacht irgendein fifa stream ich laufe immer mit uniform durch den frankfurt
hauptbahnhof das ist auch eine sache für mich für sich kann ich mir vorstellen also
ich war jetzt ja schon eine weile nicht mehr am hauptbahnhof in frankfurt weil weil home
office und jetzt schon seit über einem monat urlaub und sowas aber immer wenn ich da bin
ist irgendwas anderes ja also es ist eigentlich nur also nee muss ich anders sagen es ist
im prinzip immer das gleiche aber in leicht anderer variante also heute ist der kotzfleck
nicht links sondern rechts so nach dem motto ja heute liegt einer auf der treppe morgen
liegt er auf der treppe heute liegt gegen eine spritze guck da aus dem müll einmal
raus morgen da es ist immer der gleiche scheiß aber leicht abgewandelt definition of insanity
quasi random es ist wie wenn es sieht sich ändert jeden jeden tag nachts wird der hauptbahnhof
neu gesiedelt startet mit einem neuen sieht am nächsten tag wenn du den sieht weißt könntest
du quasi daraus errechnen was am hauptbahnhof wann passiert was wollte ich denn jetzt eigentlich
sagen ich habe doch mit was ganz was anderem angefangen leute ach so ja fresskoma irgendwas
mit fresskoma auf der arbeit es gibt eine sache nächstes jahr für die arbeit was
tatsächlich passieren könnte erstens muss ich muss ein bisschen ausholen ich habe dieses
jahr relativ gut stonks gemacht mit youtube und twitch ich habe ein paar placements gemacht
ich habe jetzt ein manager ihr könnt euch vorstellen wusstet ihr dass ich ein manager
hat mittlerweile sagen gibt es noch ein paar sachen noch ein paar sachen geplant und die
sagen wir so wie soll ich sagen so so budget ranges haben sich seit 2010 zu heute doch
schon ganz schön erweitert wenn man eben ein channel ist wo noch ein paar leute zugucken
und dazu kommt also dass du als vorgeschichte wie heißt mein manager ich kann euch auf twitter
zeigen ja ja was auch witzig ist
wie das dazu gekommen ist ich habe modern warfare keys verlost und er hat zufälliger
weise jetzt wirklich zufälliger weise einen key gewonnen von irgendwie 800 leuten oder
so ich hatte fünf zehn keys oder so 800 leute zusammen geschrieben und er hat zufälliger
weise den key gewonnen und dann haben wir danach mal zufälliger weise ein bisschen modern
warfare gespielt ein bisschen gelabert im discord und irgendwie hat sich das dann mit
der zeit zu ergeben also manchmal sind die zufälle doch irgendwie witzig ja so also wie
gesagt erstens läuft es ganz gut mit twitch und youtube aber ihr wisst ja nach wie vor
ich werde das nie vollzeit machen aber was nächstes jahr passieren könnte ist folgendes
die sind bei mir auf der arbeit ja habe ich euch ja schon öfters erzählt ein bisschen
wie könnte man das jetzt ausdrücken etwas letztes jahr 1000 könnte man glaube ich sagen
ich meine man hat jetzt nicht nur bei uns aber uns natürlich im speziellen auch auf
der arbeit hat man jetzt gesehen dass das mit home office und allem wunderbar funktioniert
aber die sind halt so old school old school konservativ ja wie auch wenn man das auch
ich sag mal so aus dem letzten jahr 1000 wie gesagt unser durchschnittsalter auf der arbeit
ist keine ahnung 43 oder so ich bin noch ich bin noch jünger ich bin noch eine jüngerin
bei uns aber frankfurt bankenställts ja aber richtig boomer aller und jetzt sind sie ja
gerade gezwungen home office anzubieten durch gesetzliche regelung weiß nicht wer das
ist und die haben aber letztens gesagt dass es wahrscheinlich ein home office im größeren
umfang geben wird wenn corona vorbei ist da kann sich noch vieles dran ändern außerdem
hat es auch nur ein typ gesagt mal gucken was dann wirklich kommt das steht ja noch
alles in den sternen aber trotzdem dass alles wunderbar läuft und gerade für mich eigentlich
mit home office alles besser ist ich schaffe mehr auf der arbeit ich habe mehr zeit für
meine sachen das ist gesundheitlich auch viel besser ja ich muss ich kann ich kann allein
schon die eineinhalb stunden die ich morgens nicht verschenke das ist einfach gold wert
du bist viel viel wacher und dementsprechend fühlst du dich auch viel gesunder gesünder
ich esse gescheite sachen wenn ich daheim bin im vergleich zu frankfurt und am schritt
bewege ich mich sogar mehr ich habe keine probleme mehr was rücken und kopfschmerzen
angeht und sonst was also für alle beteiligten ist home office zumindest IT technisch bei
uns andere abteilung kann ich nicht sagen einfach das beste was es gibt aber sie wollen
nicht so mal gucken wie das nächstes jahr wirklich wird aber es kann sein dass wenn
die wirklich darauf bestehen sollten was schwierig wird weil sogar der betriebsrat bei uns schon
gesagt hat gibt es nicht ihr habt das und die haben ja lustigerweise vorher schon was
unterschrieben dass es home office technisch geregelt ist was auch immer zumindest sollten
die das wirklich durchdrücken wollen somit es gibt kein kein überwiegendes home office
also kein überwiegendes home office bedeutet quasi maximal zwei tage die woche logischerweise
weil fünf tage kannst du nicht gescheit teilen das heißt das höchste der gefühle ist zwei
tage home office drei tage arbeit gut bei mir eh weniger weil ich bin nur noch vier
tage da und es könnte sein dass es sagen das gibt es nicht so dann könnte es nächstes
jahr passieren dass ich auf dass ich auf drei tage woche reduziere weil ich sehe das nicht
mehr ein jetzt wo ich gesehen habe wie gut das funktioniert dass es für alle beteiligten
das beste ist und dass es mir sowohl geistig als auch generell gesundheitlich besser geht
dabei wenn ich da nicht so oft hinfahre sehe ich das nicht mehr ein also dann könnte es
wirklich sein dass ich sage ich arbeite nur noch drei tage die woche dann mache ich halt
bitten noch mehr youtube und twitch stonks unterm strich und das ist ja gerade der witz
dabei unterm strich verdiene ich dann wahrscheinlich sogar mehr wenn ich das wenn ich das ernsthafter
mache also aber ich werde nie vollzeit machen soviel soviel bmw sicher ist das für gedudel
ach so ah ok ich hab gar keine nintendo playlist wobei sony ist ja nicht sony sonic ist ja
mittlerweile spaß quasi schon fast nintendo da zu hause ja sega macht ja nichts eigenes
mehr ein bisschen leiser kann man machen oder und jetzt wird auch gesungen exzellent warum
ich vollzeit machen will dazu sage ich auch gleich was warum ich vollzeit machen will
weil ich das bei anderen leuten gesehen also das ist einer der punkt einer der punkte
weil ich das bei anderen content creator gesehen habe wozu das führt wenn du das vollzeit
machst du nimmst die sache einfach so wichtiger als sie es wert ist genommen zu werden was
aber auch ganz klar ist beim krieger zwischenzeitlich auf jeden fall aber mittlerweile auch nicht
mehr du nimmst die sache viel ernster also du youtube wird dann viel mehr zum lebensinhalt
was ja auch klar ist ich meine dann finanzielle zukunft hängt davon ab aber wenn ich heute
sehe youtuber xy biefen sich oder was weiß ich irgendeiner würde mal ein video machen
ansage an max oder was auch immer irgendwas dann wird mir das reichlich am arsch vorbeigehen
aber wenn du so was vollzeit machst und du komplett davon abhängig bist dann siehst
du das alles ein bisschen anders und du musst dann auch content produzieren ob du willst
oder nicht und es fällt dann auch manchmal ein bisschen schwer einfach nur das rauszuhauen
was du willst zum beispiel zum beispiel guckt euch englischsprachige battlefield youtuber
an das hat ewig gedauert das hat ewig gedauert bis dort mal jemand die klappe aufgemacht
hat und einfach mal gesagt hat klartext wie es ist das spiel ist unterste schublade und
absolut scheiße und warum und warum hat es so lange gedauert weil die genau überlegen
mussten kann ich das machen die mussten genau überlegen oder den zeitpunkt abwarten wo
sie sich sicher sind dass die fanboy meinung zum größten teil umgeschwappt ist und dass
sie nichts an vorteilen verlieren dadurch das jetzt zu sagen und das sind so sachen
wo ich mir einfach keine gedanken machen will also das comeback des faxes das muss ja nicht
kommen becken angeblich werden die korona zahlen ja noch per fax ausgetauscht also ultra
krass bezahlt bin ich jetzt anett ich hab doch ein video gemacht wie viel ich verdiene da
geht noch da wird also wenn ich den job wechseln würde und auch wenn ich bei vier tagen bleibe
können ich deutlich mehr verdienen als dort wo ich jetzt bin aber es ist halt so auf der
anderen seite ist das krass immer grüner ich hatte sogar schon angebote mittlerweile
unter anderem von leuten die früher bei uns gearbeitet haben die mich dann zwischenzeitlich
angerufen haben hier max kommst du irgendwie für keine ahnung 80k zu uns oder sowas oder
noch mehr teilweise das war richtig hart aber ich habe ich Leute hier weiß ich was mich
erwartet ich weiß welche leute mir auf den sack gehen und welche nicht und ehrlich gesagt
ich habe mit youtube so viel ausgleich ich brauche nichts anderes mal meinst du wirklich
auf programmierzeug auf youtube guckt doch gar keiner die meisten mussten die meisten
gucken englisch sprachige sachen ich gucke ja ja ich gucke ja selten Leute ich weiß
dass es welche gibt die das gucken aber im deutschsprachigen bereich doch nicht wirklich
also der beste channel der mir das so einfällt ist zum beispiel er hier und hier habe ich
auch schon was zusammen gemacht wir machen demnächst machen wir doch wieder was zusammen
klar der hat schon super aufrufe teilweise wenn die wenn die themen passen aber das ist
halt in deutsch den deutschsprachig sehr niche noch
das stimmt wobei ich weiß ich ob das so gut ankommt ich könnte mit indischen akzent
auf mit mit indischen englischen akzent programmier tutorials auf youtube machen ja
hold on hold on was ist denn coding bullet code bullet die meinst du oder hat aber auch
schon lange nichts mehr gemacht also ich habe gesehen dass wenn ich die passenden themen
habe was so technik sachen angeht dass die durchaus auch gute aufrufe bekommen gut das
letzte jetzt vielleicht nicht so aber die videos brauchen immer zwei drei wochen bis
die auf bis sie abpicken die die zahlen viele von meinen zuschauen gucken die videos nicht
aber durch die suche kommen immer relativ viele das war bei den letzten videos auch das dauert
teilweise zwei drei vier wochen haben die 40k oder mehr das eine hat sogar über 100.000
mittlerweile aber die sachen gehen immer ganz gut wenn es was sagen wir so was was mit mit
aktuellen bezug ist oder halt irgendwas was halt die leute auch interessiert wo die leute
suchen weil hier sehe ich das ja von meinen leuten guckt das kaum einer auf youtube das
sehe ich ja in der statistik das konnten dann irgendwie keine ahnung 9 bis 10 prozent
der der abonnenten normal ist also normal am anfang sind so über 20 prozent und das
geht dann runter so auf auf 16 17 prozent aber unter 10 prozent ist halt schlecht und
diese videos haben immer am anfang unter 10 prozent aber nach zwei drei tagen wenn es
halt was aktuelles ist und youtube merkt die leute suchen sogar danach und finden dann mal
ein video gucken das dann zehn minuten plus an dann wird es empfohlen und wird gezeigt
das ist halt cool also der youtube algorithmus ist wirklich nicht schlecht in der richtung
und watch time ist halt eh eines der wichtigsten sachen das video deswegen weiß ich auch genau
dass dieses video in vier fünf wochen keine ahnung 40 40.000 plus aufruf hat weil es
über zwölf minuten zwölf halb minuten watch time hat das ist fast die hälfte von video
ja patrick genau da hast du recht ja
deswegen ich würde das ich würde das und da hast du halt und da hast du auch ach ja
das kenne ich das kenne ich das das haben wir sogar schon mal geguckt im stream zusammen
glaube ich ja das ist genau das ist das was ich halt auch nicht machen will ich kann jetzt
wirklich random dinger machen ich mache stream an ich mein ich glaube viel viel random mäßiger
kann ja ein kann ja twitch content kaum sein ich meine da ist ja quasi alles da ist ja
quasi alles mögliche dabei guckt euch das mal an heute laber stellts gestern und vorgestern
vorgestern swell kit app bauen und bisschen hetzen und sellout machen davor irgendwie
gelaber dann irgendwie stellenanzeigen angeguckt aufwachen stream danach bisschen battlefield
gespielt dann irgendwelche java dinger ausprobiert dann microcontroller gebastelt dann battlefield
2042 gespielt dann laber stream gemacht dann irgendwie mit dem chat zusammen aufgeräumt
also das ist schon wilde wilde mischung alles ja
also ich sag mal konzept kann man das nicht unbedingt nennen
naja also das ist das was vielleicht 2022 ins haus steht
nämlich vielleicht nur noch drei tage die woche arbeiten mal gucken ich hoffe ja die
kommen zur besinnung weil ach moin er sich jetzt erst weil das witzige ist ich kenne
schon einen der zum ende des jahres gekündigt hat unter anderem wegen diesen wegen dieser
nicht klaren linie was das thema home office angeht und ihr wisst wie es ist leute jetzt
mal ehrlich chat wer sind die ersten leute die kündigen wenn ihnen was nicht passt was
sind die ersten leute die abhauen
die progas die guten die jungen vielleicht ja die jungen aber vor allem die guten leute
und vor allem und vor allem die guten leute die auch nicht faul sind also die guten leute
die auch was arbeiten also quasi das was man unbedingt behalten will weil die guten leute
die finden zwar was anderes aber allein gut zu sein kann ja auch sein du bist ultra faul
das ist halt das bei mir ich will mich nicht selbst loben das klingt immer ultra bescheuern
aber ich glaube man sieht auch anhand der sachen die wir hier im stream machen dass ich doch
relativ breit gefächert mich auskenne und in manchen themen gebieten doch schon ganz
gut und nachdem ich auch schon angebote bekommen habe für deutlich mehr von anderen ist das
ok das ist durchaus auch gefragt aber ich bin halt ultra extremst faul was sowas angeht
so die jungen und die fleißigen leute die sind zuerst weg also die jungen die guten
und die fleißigen leute zuerst weg
und das habe ich auch gesehen kollege von mir auf der arbeit also um zwei ecken da war
mal bei uns jetzt aber in anderen abteilung haben wir die habe ich mich gut verstanden
der hat gesagt er hört jetzt auf ende des jahres geht woanders hin aber auch innerhalb
von frankfurt also er geht quasi wenn er so will zwei häuser weiter da jetzt was angenommen
weil eben dieser random umgang mit home office und diese nicht klare line überhaupt nicht
gefällt ihm das voll ans anpisst und er geht jetzt einfach ok kann ich kann ich verstehen
ja hatte wer mal ein schaumy handy geflasht ne habe nie gemacht
ich habe mich gerade ausgeliehen zu 50 prozent an eine andere firma und verdiene damit easy
genug mein geld plus miete für unser büro und ein 50 prozent produktionsmitarbeiter
zu bezahlen man braucht absolut nicht wunderbar das stimmt und es stimmt auch für andere
bereiche das muss man nicht in der schweiz arbeiten es ist sicherlich wie sage ich jetzt
es ist sicherlich ein vorteil oder ein vorzug in so einer branche zu arbeiten wie ich weil
du arbeitest dich ja definitiv körperlich nicht tot oder so es ist zwar manchmal geistig
anstrengend und auch stressig aber ich glaube dass man es nicht mit dem stress von sagen
man im chirurg vergleichen kann wenn er gerade merkt auf fack es läuft nicht richtig oder
mit einem pilot oder mit einem flug lotse oder mit körperlicher arbeit was auf baustellen
oder bei mauchern oder so passiert ja und also das ist schon hat schon echt seine vorteil
in der branche zu arbeiten du schaffst dich körperlich nicht kaputt klar es ist manchmal
stressig aber du verdienst relativ gut und das stimmt man muss nicht 100 prozent arbeiten
und ich habe dafür jetzt keine belege und ich habe dafür jetzt auch keine statistiken
parat aber könnt ihr mal zu sagen was ihr was ihr davon dazu denkt ich habe den eindruck
dass gerade die summa generation die jetzt quasi auch angefangen haben gerade anfangen
zu arbeiten oder vielleicht auch die generation die schon angefangen hat zu arbeiten angefangen
hat zu arbeiten dass viele von denen besonders darauf gucken dass aber nicht mehr ihr leben
ist und dass sie quasi so viel arbeiten wie nötig aber nicht quasi bis zum umfallen also
ich kenne zum beispiel zwei bei uns die mehr oder weniger nach der ausbildung direkt teilzeit
arbeiten wollen das habe ich vorher noch nie gehört
zumindest ist es mein eindruck dass es gerade bei der besonders jungen generation viele
gibt die arbeit tatsächlich als das sehen was es ist so als mittel zum zweck wir reden
jetzt nicht davon du hast eine eigene firma gegründet oder sowas da hast du ja auch ganz
andere engagement andere verpflichtungen und andere rangehensweise wenn es deine eigene
firma ist davon rede ich ja nicht sondern wenn ihr einfach nur irgendwo arbeitet und
ihr da auch jetzt nicht super involviert sind in den laden das ist poggers das ist auch
witzig ne wisst ihr wie die das bei uns begründen ich habe ja schon gesagt die sind da sehr
oldschool und konservativ was homeoffice sachen angeht der wollte allen ernstes die
karte ziehen bei der begründung warum die das machen ja bei uns wird es voraussichtlich
also bei uns wird es kein übermäßiges homeoffice geben und so nach dem motto wir müssen ja
die leute vor sich selbst beschützen das hat er so nicht gesagt aber seine begründung
war wir haben ja auch schon also man würde ja auch sehen dass die leute quasi psychische
probleme bekommen wenn sie zu viel homeoffice haben ganz ehrlich lass das mal das problem
der leute sein und nicht wir müssen wir müssen quasi vorgeschoben was erzählen was eigentlich
nur für uns gut ist also das das das habe ich ihm nicht abgekauft das stimmt ja da
hast du recht ich hatte mal ich hatte mal ein kollege auf der arbeit ein dehne extrem netter
kerl der hat aber halt auch wirklich sein leben gechillt kann man so sagen er hat es
richtig gemacht er hat komplett sein leben gechillt da war teilweise bis 22 uhr da oder
so und hat dafür als externe auch abkassiert aber der war halt auch morgens erst mal zwei
stunden mühsli essen der hat echt sein leben gechillt komplett und externen stundenlohn
kassiert der hat es genau richtig gemacht und der hat auch öfters mal ärger gekriegt
weil die sachen die fertig wurden die er machen sollte irgendwann hat es dann auch dazu geführt
dass er halt seinen vertrag nicht verlängert bekommen hat aber da geht er halt einfach
woanders hin das hat den alles nicht geschockt der hat wirklich sein leben gechillt ganzen
tag so muss das machen so ist richtig wirklich wirklich wir lernen ja schon auf youtube muss
hasseln leute hascheln hasche wie wie spricht er das aus muss hascheln ich kann es nicht ich
kann kein schwäbisch aussprechen hascheln
ich gucke den kram nicht ich kenne bloß die ganzen memes davon gibt es den er den gibt
es wahrscheinlich noch es gibt so leute die gehen nicht weg bis der ins treibs ehrlich
finde ich auch habe ich früher gar nicht so gesehen also als ich noch ausbildung gemacht
habe damit der ausbildung fertig war da habe ich das so als normal angesehen so nach dem
motto für stunden die arbeit ist normal aber im endeffekt überlegt man wie wenig zeit
man eigentlich für die sachen hat die einem spaß machen und ich sage jetzt nicht dass
nicht die aber durchaus auch spaß machen kann aber man wirklich frei entscheiden kann
was man mit seiner zeit macht und wo man seinen zeit investiert überlegt man wenn ihr 40
stunden die woche arbeitet wenn ihr 40 stunden die woche aber ich kenne ich kenne das ich
kenne das ja von mir noch du stehst meistens also gibt es zwei zwei leute na ich war eher
der frühaufsteher dass ich früh heim gehen konnte aber trotzdem war es im sommer im winter
teilweise so dass du es war morgens dunkel und es war quasi wenn du heim gekommen bist
schon wieder dunkel so und du hast eins bis zwei stunden am tag damit zugebracht irgendwie
hin und zurück zu kommen von der arbeit auf die arbeit dann hast du deine siebeneinhalb
stunden acht stunden je nachdem wie viel es genau sind auf der arbeit was gemacht oder
oftmals auch nur zeit abgesessen dann muss ja auch mal ehrlich sagen es ist auf der arbeit
nicht die ganze zeit immer super krass was los was auch gut gut so ist würde ja gar
nicht funktionieren aber manchmal ist es auch einfach nur zeit absetzen einfach anwesend
sein und das hast du gemacht so und das hast du am montag das hast du dann gemacht montags
bis freitag freitags warst du so müde also ich war ich war unter der woche schon immer
extrem müde ich habe das aber nie so richtig realisiert erst jetzt als ich teilzeit arbeite
du bist in einer woche schon müde dass du eigentlich 22 ins bett gefallen bist ich
bin sogar manchmal vom rechner daheim eingepennt so dann warst du freitag nach der arbeit müde
hast eigentlich nichts mehr gemacht bist mehr oder weniger penng gegangen wie unter der
woche samstag musstest du dann ein bisschen was was machen was halt gemacht werden muss
von vielleicht mal sachen einkaufen bis mal was aufräumen mal irgendwas reparieren mal
irgendwie halt dinger machen die nicht zur arbeit gehören ich habe das auch nach der
azubi zeit noch gemacht ich arbeite ja noch nicht na doch ich arbeite auch schon eine
ganze weile teilzeit jetzt aber aber nicht sein anfang an so und die einzige zeit die
du wirklich hattest ist samstag nachmittag bis sonntag mittag wo du ein bisschen das
machen konntest was du willst wenn du jetzt natürlich familie hast oder frau kinder sonst
was dann machst du natürlich mit denen was ansonsten hast ansonsten hast du halt quasi
ein tag fast was du machen kannst was du willst und ab sonntag mittag machst du dir eigentlich
schon wieder gedanken morgen gehts wieder los auf der arbeit früh aufstehen ah fuck
kein bock so und das ist so die 40 arbeitsstunde die 40 stunden arbeitswoche und das sagt
halt einfach das ist mega beschissen deswegen ich kann jedem der sich das geld technisch
leisten kann nur dazu raten einen tag die woche weniger zu arbeiten das bringt unglaublich
viel allein schon weil du dir sonntags keine gedanken machst dass du montags wieder aufstehen
musst und du hast den ganzen sonntag um das zu machen was du willst du hast den ganzen
montag das zu machen was du willst vor allem ist es auch ein wochentag dass du kannst
dann da auch wirklich mal was machen wenn du was machen musst oder machen willst und dadurch
dass du quasi drei tage am stück frei hast bist du eigentlich montag abend gar nicht
so böse darum dass du dienstag wieder arbeiten musst
so wie gesagt das sind das sind meine erfahrungen damit deswegen kann ich jedem nur wärmstens
ans herz legen seine arbeitszeit zu reduzieren das ist auch kein problem da gibt es sogar
gesetzliche regelungen zu also klar man kann euch immer fristgerecht kündigen aus fadenscheinlichen
gründen was aber keiner macht wenn ihr gut seid warum sollte man sollte man das machen
ansonsten kann man euch das nicht verbieten die die arbeitgeber können höchsten sagen
das geht gerade nicht weil wichtig für betriebssachen und so der kann jetzt nicht weniger arbeiten
aber dann sind die verpflichtet abhilfe zu schaffen innerhalb von kürzerer zeit dass
das geht also eigentlich kann man es euch gar nicht verbieten teilzeit zu arbeiten also
ich kann es wirklich jedem nur nahe legen das zu machen ja kann ich verstehen 40 stunden
ist ja auch kacke würde ich machen würde ich machen 27 immer noch super alter für
die ausbildung ja gut kann man kann man alles mal letztendlich ist ja wichtig dass man selbst
damit gut klar kommt wenn man jetzt in ihrem job arbeitet wo man sagt hey das ist für mich
so die krasse erfüllung dass es ja kaum arbeit ist warum nicht ja und ich muss sagen wir
macht auch einiges spaß auf der arbeit aber ich kann trotzdem mir eine bessere investition
für meine zeit vorstellen als zu arbeiten es ist nicht so dass ich denke fack ich muss
auf die arbeit gar nicht ich finde das eigentlich nicht schlecht ist es nicht so dass ich übelste
glücksgefühle habe morgens wenn ich aufstehe und sage ja wohl ich darf jetzt wieder arbeiten
gehen ich glaube das hast du bei den wenigsten sachen wobei das stimmt gar nicht ich habe
manche an manchen tagen wenn irgendwelche coolen sachen sind wo ich weiß dass irgendwas
kommt wo ich bock drauf habe da freue ich mich tatsächlich manchmal wirklich auf die
arbeit zu gehen kann alles mögliche sein von irgendwie neuer software oder einfach nur
weil ich weiß heute wird das und das gemacht und ich bin schadenfroh weil ich sehen wie
es in die hose geht oder sowas keine ahnung kann alles mögliche sein aber kommt oft genug
vor dass ich mich tatsächlich freue sage ich bin gespannt was rauskommt
ja so mache ich ja deswegen mache ich sie auch grad so altgebackene chef etagen sind
triggert ja bei uns erzählen sie dann immer so so fadenscheinige sprüche so nach dem
motto wir sind ein unternehmen was traditionell dafür steht dass wir von menschen für menschen
arbeiten und sowas denke ich mir mal da sind wir die wohlfahrt oder was wir sind eine bank
wir verkaufen den leuten versicherungen und machen den ihr geld das hört sich immer
an als sind wir irgendwie so ein wohltätigkeitsverein wenn die sowas erzählen das das triggert
mich immer richtig was ein dummes gelaber aber gut das sind halt das sind halt so sachen
was willst du sagen wir sind definitiv nicht die wohlfahrt wir sind wir sind gewinnorientierte
stonks unternehmen wir tun dann immer so als macht man was für die menschheit das wirklich
so bei uns weiß ich ob das einer von sich von der arbeit kennt bei uns tun die wirklich
so als würden wir was für die menschheit machen dabei verdienen wir an denen geld
wir können ja gar nichts wirklich zum wohle der menschheit machen die tun immer so als
sind wir wirklich die aller krassesten leute und und sorgen für das wohlergehen der menschheit
könnte kaum weiter entfernt von der realität sein und das beste ist das beste bei uns ist
auf der arbeit immer noch wenn dann irgendwelche größeren veran- oh ich muss schon ein bisschen
musikleiser machen wohl aber es ist zu laut wenn dann irgendwelche größeren veranstaltungen
da sind und dann bringen die dann bringen die halt genau solche sprüche so und so nach
dem motto ja wir stehen dafür dass wir für menschen arbeiten und uns für menschen einsetzen
und da dafür stehen wir sagt dann einer auf der bühne oder gibt es dann so viele leute
die da im publikum sitzen und dann aufstehen teilweise jawoll easy clap so ist es jawoll
ja man ist es geil hier zu arbeiten und wisst ihr was das schlimme ist die meinen das ernst
die meinen das wirklich ernst die springen da auf und sind mega gehyped und ich denke
mir so jedes mal facepalm so denke ich alle leute wir sind doch hier kein wohltätigkeitsverein
wir machen das nur um geld zu verdienen und die sind richtig krass gehyped die meinen
das wirklich ernst ich meine ich sage nicht dass wir irgendwie schlimm sind oder so wissen
wir sind aber weder besser noch schlechter als die anderen im endeffekt muss die kohle
noch irgendwo herkommen ja deswegen mache ich es auch nicht wie gesagt ich habe gemerkt
dass diese quasi bei mir sind es ja drei tage home office einen tag auf die arbeit fahren
dass ich so viel alles also dass dass ich gesünder bin im kopf körperlich auch leistungsfähiger
für die für die arbeit ich da insgesamt mehr mache ich frage mich immer an dem einen
tag wo ich auf die arbeit fahre wenn ich dann mittags im zug sitze was hast du eigentlich
gemacht nix hast nix da kommt dann irgend einer rum und sagt auch max auch mal wieder da dann
erzählt sie mit dem zehn minuten dann willst du mal ganz kurz bei dem einen vorbei und den
fragen so nach dem otto und habt ihr das jetzt schon gefixt aber nebenbei fragt er dich dann
und hast du deine jelly schon eingebaut in die steckdose bis wieder eine halbe stunde
am labern dann hast du irgendwelche daily dinger die natürlich auch viel länger gehen wenn
wenn das ganze vor ort ist hast du hier und da immer irgendwas an noch das ganze hin und
zurück fahren ich mache an den tagen kaum was ist es nicht dass ich wirklich drauf anlegen
würde dort nix zu machen aber es ist einfach so viel ineffektiver versus daheim vom rechner
sitzen es ist jeder da es ist jeder erreichbar und du findest auch sofort ein wenn du einen
brauchst und kümmerst dich einfach um deine probleme und gut ist hast du eigentlich ein
extra arbeitszimmer ja ich habe einen extra arbeitszimmer in dem sinn aber das ist auch
das gleiche zimmer wo ich drinnen streame und und hier meine meine technik habe aber
das ist ein extra arbeitszimmer dafür quasi man könnte ja auch ja ich meine ich nenne
es arbeitszimmer manch einer würde sagen gamingraum oder was auch immer aber das ist
mein arbeitszimmer schreibt ihr schön verstellbarer schreibt nicht am start ordentlicher stuhl
hier viel zu teurer stuhl bei dabei kann ich keinem empfehlen zu kaufen aber geiler stuhl
zwei rechner zwei monitore so wie man sich eigentlich das vorstellt ja das verstehe
ich auch nicht das verstehe ich auch nicht auch da fällt mir auch noch eine sache ein
was ich halt auch immer ein bisschen bitter finde wir haben bei uns ich kenne das im support
klar jetzt werden die leute wieder sagen luld support da kannst du auch nichts anderes
erwarten aber wir haben im support tatsächlich ein paar studierte informatiker sitzen also
die müssten eigentlich ein bisschen was verstehen von dem was sie machen und so ein studium
schafft ja auch nicht jeder aber die arbeiten quasi im support support meine ich jetzt nicht
endkunden support sondern support ist eigentlich das falsche wort aber ich nenne es mal support
eigentlich geht es um eskalation eskalations management und 24 7 überwachung aber ich
nenne es ich nenne es mal ich nenne es mal support so und da sind leute dabei also ich
weiß ich weiß das von zweien die verdienen da jetzt ganz ok es ist jetzt nicht dass
die übermäßig viel verdienen aber ich weiß nicht wie die das machen aber die schaffen
es quasi so von paycheck zu paycheck zu leben und das liegt nicht am support oder so ich
sage jetzt so ich weiß dass halt von zwei leuten die da arbeiten bei uns und das tut
mir da immer ein bisschen leid so um die leute wo ich denke ok es hat halt nicht jeder den
luxus wie ich dass ich erstens ein job habe wo ich mich körperlich nicht kaputt mache
zusätzlich vier tage nur noch arbeiten muss trotzdem ganz gut verdiene ein haus geerbt
habe und keine familie also keine keine kinder hab ich mein mir gehts da eigentlich schon
ganz gut ja ich mein was ich sage ich hab da gut reden wenn ich hier sitze und sag
ja leute arbeitet man nur vier tage es gibt halt genug die da ganz andere existenzängste
haben was ich klar wollte ich jetzt an der stelle auch bloß noch mal sagen es ist jetzt
aber nicht so dass ich dir so von meinem hohen ross runter sagen will so nach dem motto macht
es mal alle ich weiß schon dass das war eigentlich auch schlichter greif nicht geht so ok was
seno platz nach meiner erfahrung ist das gerade konservative unternehmen zum beispiel maschinenbau
die fans space ein problem mit home office apple ja auch apple ja auch die hatten ja
richtig stress deswegen bin ich wieder zu hause wenn die leute netflix und wisst ihr
was der witz ist ich finde das ist der falsche ansatz es ist scheiß egal ob die leute zu
hause netflix schauen oder nicht wenn die mehr arbeiten also mehr ergebnisse schaffen
als vor ort ist es scheiß egal ob die netflix gucken oder nicht wenn einer super krass
programmieren kann und nebenbei eine serie gucken soll er machen was interessiert sie denn also
wenn einer 20 tick ich nehme es mal tickets ist immer eine schöne sache da kann man es
zumindest so halbwegs tracken aber natürlich sind tickets unterschiedlich zeit auch wenn
ich aber so sagen wir so wenn im durch werden stellen euch mal vor einer arbeitet im support
der schafft wenn er vor ort ist 10 tickets am tag von daheim 15 daheim guckt der netflix
ja wunderbar so wort scheint trotzdem besser zu laufen oder also ich meine es wen interessiert
es eigentlich was die leute daheim machen solange die leistung stimmt und die ergebnisse
stimmen ist doch da kann der der kann den handstand machen und auf dem klo sitzen den
ganzen tag mit dem laptop doch scheiß egal wenn es besser funktioniert ok geht noch
weiter deswegen bin ich mir zu meinen vorherigen unternehmen zurück wir sind eh verteilt dies
aber ein projekt von verschiedenen standorten mittlerweile auch top in deiner physik ausbild
das geht überhaupt nicht darfst überhaupt keine azubis 60 bis 80 stunden arbeiten lassen
über stunden als azubis gerade wenn du noch minderjährig bist dann ist noch krasser geht
überhaupt nicht also geht mal schon aber nicht dauerhaft darfst du gar nicht ich würde
sogar so weit gehen und sagen das ist illegal gerade bei azubis ja es gibt so lehen leute
dort wo ich meine ausbildung gemacht habe beim provider ich ich ich ich verrate euch
nicht welcher ja das haben jetzt schon ein paar mal gab aber ein provider da war das
auch oftmals so da hattest du leute die waren gefühlt immer da du hast morgens geguckt
um halb sieben der war da du hast abends geguckt um zwanzig oder dreißig der war da was auch
nicht was sie da gemacht haben und ich war ja manchmal auch vor also ich habe ja ich
habe die ganze zeit schon in frankfurt gearbeitet aber der hauptstandort dieses providers war
woanders und ich war auch manchmal in der zentrale und da war das auch so die hatten
dann so komische rituale wie abends kann man doch noch mal zusammen irgendwie ein bier
trinken oder sowas und da hatten die oben so also das war ein bisschen größeres gebäude
und die hatten so quasi unterm dach hatten die nicht unterm dach also obergeschoss hatten
die so eine so eine bar und da sind die abends um 17 uhr wenn die fertig arbeiten waren da
hingegangen und die leute hatten quasi so das den den das pflicht bewusst sein die
dürfen nicht gehen bevor das da oben anfängt so nach dem auto total wir und als ich neu
war muss ich sagen ich kann das ja nicht besser und ihr wisst dass ich so soziale anlässe
hasse ich muss auch mit meinen kollegen kann bier trinken oder sowas was sie nicht heißt
dass ich die nicht mag oder so gibt durchaus leute auf der arbeit die ich jetzt mittlerweile
so lange kenne wo ich sogar sagen würde das sind so was wie freunde mittlerweile aber trotzdem
müsste ich nicht mit den leuten abends irgendwie bier trinken hätte ich gar keinen bock drauf
und da wurde es auch komisch angeguckt wenn du einfach gesagt hast um 15 uhr 30 so leute
acht stunden sind rum ich gehe jetzt heim die haben dann so gemacht die haben erst gelacht
und dann geguckt so so nachdem oder guter witz der meines ernst
da wurde es auch komisch und da hatten auch viele und ich damals ja auch ich damals ja
auch hat man sich wirklich das schlechte gewissen machen lassen du kannst doch jetzt noch nicht
gehen ja wisst ihr was ich immer gemacht habe als ich dort beim provider in der zentrale
war meistens war ich da bloß zwei tage ab und zu mal also einmal mit übernachten das
erste was ich gemacht habe nachdem ich dann dort fertig war bin ich auf dem rückweg erst
einmal mcdonalds vorbeigefahren und habe massiv riesen pippo fett gemacht das war noch die
zeit wo ich noch zu mcdonalds gegangen bin jetzt gehe ich nicht mehr zu mcdonalds ich
habe seit fünf jahren keine mcdonalds ohne scheiß bestimmt fünf jahren keine mcdonalds
gegessen ich hatte nach meiner ausbildung dieses jahr den ganzen feiern wieder angefangen
zu arbeiten aber sieht man halt aber ist nicht unbedingt das leben
das ist ein guter punkt kommt ja auch noch dabei seit ich home office mache bin ich
viel mehr bereit auch mal zu sagen wir mal unnormaleren zeiten ans telefon zu gehen auf
teams messages zu antworten überhaupt mitzubekommen dass teams messages sind abends oder gar am
sonntag mit einmal schnell was zu gucken überhaupt kein problem es ist erst eine woche her es
ist erst eine woche her hat mich ein kollege von der arbeit angeschrieben der war dann
gesehen hat gesagt ob es hat nicht gesehen dass im urlaub ist ob wir geht technisch mal
was gucken können im shit repo und da habe ich den tag später bei ihm gemeldet habe
gesagt hier weißt was ich sitze am rechner also wir können mal kurz 20 minuten gucken
ist überhaupt kein problem da habe ich mit dem letzte woche die vorletzte ich habe nicht
letzte mal die letzte vorletzte woche kurz 40 minuten mal mittags geguckt und fertig
war es das hat mich überhaupt null gestört natürlich wird das abgerechnet ja das hätte
ich früher nicht gemacht früher habe ich mir gedacht ok 1530 16 uhr ich war jetzt sieben
halbe stunden da ich bin eh müde habe keinen bock mehr ich habe weder auf das handy geguckt
noch wisst ihr noch wo mich ein arbeitskollege im streamer gesagt geschrieben hat max ruft
mal bitte an das war also das war lustig ich glaube dass das sascha war das hat im stream
geschrieben max ich habe versucht anzurufen geh mal dran wenn du schon über den twitch
stream benachrichtigt wirst ja aber ja ich bin da viel viel geneigter mal mal dran zu
gehen durch durch die ganze home office geschichte als umgedreht umgedreht mal eine frage an
die runde die in der it sind habt ihr erfahrung gesammelt dass viele aus dem team immer krank
sind also übermäßig hätte das mal mein ich sag mal es gibt bei uns auch bei mir im team
jetzt weniger aber man bekommt das überall anders ja bei uns auch mit es gibt so die
üblichen verdächtigen die doch schon verdächtig oft krank sind aber das kann auch sein dass
davon welche wirklich gesundheitliche probleme haben aber es gibt auch wieder welche die
sind halt auch immer an genau äußerst auffälligen tagen krank so nach dem motto er müsste jetzt
eine frühschicht übernehmen hoch er ist krank oder der urlaub ist am donnerstag fertig hoch
er ist am freitag krank oder ach gucke mal es ist ja einen brückentag donnerstag freitag
dann ist da zufälligerweise montag dienstag auch nicht da so was also es gibt leute bei
den häufen sich solche besonders gut terminierten glückliche fügungen was krankheitstage angeht
das finde ich auch ziemlich sus aber ehrlich gesagt ist mir scheiß egal solange die nicht
gekickt werden oder so eigentlich eigentlich ich will nicht sagen die machen es richtig
soweit will ich jetzt nicht gehen dass nicht aber eigentlich interessiert es mich nicht
wirklich wir müssen als selbst aber so im zweifel ist es selbst an schuld wenn sie
im endeffekt ihnen das zum verhängnis wird ach ja und übrigens noch mal was zu dieser
klasse schaut netflix ich kenne sogar welche bei uns die gucken esl csgo finals während
der arbeit finde ich überhaupt nicht schlimm und findet bei uns auch kaum einer wirklich
schlimm wenn es halt nebenbei läuft die einzige sache wo halt es immer schlecht ankommt ist
wenn mal irgendwie dann irgendeiner vom forstand der meinung ist ich laufe da jetzt mal ein
bisschen rum und guck mal da durch und dann sitzt halt einer da hat nebenbei irgendwie
csgo laufen auf dem handy aber die kündigen sich ja meistens vorher an
wusste dir eigentlich dass der unmittelbare weg vom hoff vom bett ins homeoffice auch
durch die berufs ja wusste ich das habe ich auch gelesen ich weiß nicht das habe ich
aber auch gelesen ich weiß nicht mal genau was passiert ist hatte sich nicht ins bein
gebrochen oder so hat sich da nicht irgendeiner das bein gebrochen beim weg vom schlafzimmer
ins arbeitszimmer und hat gesagt es ist ein arbeitsunfall und die berufsgenossenschaft
oder wer auch immer hat gesagt nein das ist kein arbeitsunfall aber das gericht hat jetzt
gesagt es ist ein arbeitsunfall war das nicht so ich habe das auch letztens irgendwo gelesen
da hat sich das bein gebrochen auf dem weg vom schlafzimmer in ins arbeitszimmer es
musste auch erst mal schaffen
die
dynamische deadlines am anfang sagt einer irgendwie bis dann und dann muss das aber
fertig sein so da sagst du leute wie soll das funktionieren
es wurde ja noch nicht mal ausgewählt was für software dafür verwendet werden soll
Woher soll man dann jetzt schon wissen, was da am ende bei rauskommt, geschweige denn wann das fertig ist, naja bis dahin muss das fertig sein
So und dann kommt es auf einmal so nach dem motto ach ja das ist doch nicht schlimm wenn es zwei monaten später fertig wird
Und das schiebt sich dann weiter so
Also freizeitechnisch ist es gerade schon schwierig mit den 40 stunden
Ich würde sehr gern einen tag weglassen, aber leider bin ich im kopf noch so
Ja gut
Mehr verdienen wollen würde wahrscheinlich jeder aber was du ja machen kannst ist
Leih an deinem chef einfach mal 400 euro mehr irgendwie aus den rippen
Und danach macht direkt teilzeit oder noch besser leih an deinem chef irgendwie 600 euro aus den rippen und macht dann teilzeit
Dann wirst du zwar nicht davon so viel behalten
Aber vielleicht hast du trotzdem insgesamt
Mehr als wenn du erst teilzeit machst und dann der gehalserhöhung kriegst wobei das bei uns nicht der fall ist
Wir rechnen das immer auf fünf tage hoch und dann wieder auf vier tage runter so dass das für alle gleich ist
Weil ansonsten hätte ich deutlich bessere chancen mehr geld zu bekommen weil es ist immer ein unterschied
Wenn einer sagt so nach dem motto was weiß ich wenn einer sagt ich will 600 euro mehr sagen
Oh das geht nicht wenn ich dann irgendwie schon
anteilmäßig weniger sage
Dann ist die chance viel höher dass die sagen ach ja das ist ja ok weil die dann nicht dran denken in dem moment dass es ja nur
Für vier tage ist
Deswegen rechnen wir das immer fünf tage hoch taktisch wäre es eigentlich umgedreht geschickter
Aber du kannst es auch gar nicht richtig vergleichen sonst
Ja
60 bis 80 stunden ist ja mega heftig da bist du ja quasi jeden da bist du quasi jeden tag 14 14 stunden
Im büro 80 stunden will soll es gehen da kannst du wirklich nichts machen außer außer schlafen
Und arbeiten mehr geht da nicht schlafen und arbeiten
Ja jetzt sehen alle dass sie irgendwie das leben der menschheit besser machen würden
Aber es zählt fast jedes größere unternehmen so nach dem motto wir tun der menschheit was gutes und nur die wenigsten machen
Und außerdem bei und recht tut ja auch nicht der menschheit was gutes um der menschheit was gutes zu tun sondern sie machen stonks
Und geld und tun nebenbei noch der menschheit was gutes
Aber das geld machen steht im vorderseiten der menschheit was gutes zu tun sondern die menschheit was gutes zu tun
Aber das geld machen steht im vordergrund
Was meint ihr jetzt jetzt bei ernsthaft stellt euch mal vor
Nehmen wir jetzt mal ein biotech
Stellt euch mal vor die hätten die auswahl zwei medikamente auf den markt zu bringen
eins also für eine krankheit sagen wir mal wie corona oder so oder für eine krankheit die wirklich schlimm also die wirklich schlimm sein kann
und die auch verbreitet ist
so
Ja mit zwei zwei medikamente zur auswahl eins was die krankheit wenn du es nimmst für immer heilt
Oder eins was du alle zwei drei jahre neu nehmen musst oder jedes halbe jahr oder jedes jahr
Welches davon würden die wahrscheinlich eher rausbringen
Da muss man nicht lange nicht lange überlegen natürlich das was du immer wieder dein ganzes leben lang nehmen musst das ziel wäre dann die geht es möglichst gut
Und du musstest ein ganzes leben lang nehmen weil unter dem strich natürlich das
Unter dem strich natürlich das was ihnen mehr geld bringt
Dass das hier das alles nur zu wohnen der menschheit
Machen da habe ich mir schon von mir schon von abgeschminkt das habe ich mir schon abgeschminkt
Was dann natürlich das gute ist wenn es ein bisschen wettbewerb in der richtung gibt
Dass dann vielleicht andere anbieter sagt ja gut dann machen wir aber das was man nur einmal nehmen muss und dann kaufen die leute alle das und
bei und hätte reingeschissen
Deswegen ist wettbewerb in dem sektor auch nicht verkehrt
Aber so viel zu dem menschheit immer was gutes weil aktuell können wir uns wirklich glücklich schätzen
Dass wir so was hier vor der haustür haben
Oder ich weiß gar nicht wo haben die eigentlich ihren sitz hier in deutschland
Haben wir noch nie mit beschäftigt
Meins
Letztes ich habe einen geilen typ in meinen youtube comments leute
Sekunde den muss ich euch mal raussuchen da müsst ihr mir müsst ihr mir mal erklären was der eigentlich was der eigentlich will
Zeige euch mal schnell moment moment
Ich muss mal kurz google mail aufmachen
Mail
Ah das ist der falsche account jetzt aber
Aber ich muss das mal kurz suchen dieser comment war wieder so unglaublich wirtschäm
Hier
Hier ich hab's ich hab's gefunden
Was genau
Was genau möchte
Was möchte der war was will er
Ich kann ich kann hat irgendjemanden plan
Warum ich warum ich mir das kommentar gemerkt habe ist
Danach habe ich mir das kommentar gemerkt hat
Warum ich warum ich mir das kommentar gemerkt habe ist danach hat er sich darüber aufgeregt dass ich den begriff corona leugner verwendet habe
Und das wäre ja ganz schlimme
Propaganda des mainstreams dass ich das so nennen würde und sowas und das kann ja so überhaupt nicht sein und schlafscharf und was auch immer
Aber was will er eigentlich
Disney 666 aber wein heroes of the storm 666 aber wein
Bungie destiny microsoft 666 wein
Der meint das ernst ne ne ne ne das ist kein troll ich habe das andere comment gelesen das meint der ernst
Das ist kein troll ich habe bloß keine ahnung was er eigentlich will von mir doch der meint das ernst
Nein das ist das ist jemand der meint das ernst
Aber ich habe keine ahnung was er mir damit überhaupt sagen will warum ist destiny 2 der teufel
Der teufel
Kennt ihr noch diesen typ kennt ihr noch den kommentar
Der auch irgendwie was gepostet hat der antichrist ist hier das mal zeichen des tieres ist unter uns
Könnt ihr euch noch an den erinnern habe ich euch da auch gezeigt oder der war auch geil
Der war auch keiner typ aller die leute sind wirklich richtig fertig
Ja ja
Und youtube comments mr. Dudel danke für den zapp habe ich gar nicht gesehen
Muss man kurz nachgucken leute
Ins ins creator dashboard ich habe bestimmt die hälfte wieder übersehen als an subscriptions ja
Husa danke für den zapp
Welche it jobs würdest du sagen sind am coolsten
Die frage was man als cool definiert also am also hip sind gerade so sachen wie data science und agile coaches und
Data science und agile coaches und irgendwelche blockchain technologie geschichten
Da sind die hippen gerade ai
So wer hat noch abonniert mr. Dudel danke für den zapp daniel lull auch am start
Ah vor zwei stunden ich habe kaum was übersehen das ist doch nice
Fange im august eine ausbildung zum fachinformatiker für systemintegration an meinung
Wie meinung zu was dass du eine ausbildung anfängst das finde ich gut
Auch wenn ich dich nicht kenne persönlich aber ich bin es gut dass du eine ausbildung anfängst ansonsten was soll ich sagen
Ich habe keine ahnung in welchem betrieb noch sonstige raumbedingungen kann ich jetzt nichts großartig zu sagen
Da hast du nicht unrecht
Da hast du nicht unrecht wobei das erst ein bisschen auf über oberer management eben anfängt
Also mein teamleiter ist nicht so der klassische chef in dem sinn der dann quasi rumläuft und permanent irgendwie
Den leuten über über über
Schulter guckt ob die auch was arbeiten das ist dann eher so quasi richtung abteilungsleiter wenn überhaupt wobei das man
Auch nicht so ist also mein chef nimmt seine koordination koordination aufgabe
Doch dann doch noch ernster und ist meistens den ganzen tag auch mit irgendwas in dieser richtung beschäftigt
Das ist teilweise richtig schwer den mal zu erwischen wenn du ihn was fragen willst weil er laufen auf irgendwelchen komischen meetings ist
Ja aber dass das insofern gebe ich dir schon recht zu diese klassische variante
Ich bin chef nicht weil ich was wichtiges mache oder weil ich irgendwie
Ich habe nicht ich habe es nicht verdient respektiert zu werden weil ich irgendwie
Sagen ich habe nicht ich habe es nicht verdient respektiert zu werden weil ich ihm diese gute sachen machen sondern einfach nur weil ich
Dein chef bin so nach dem motto zu diesen leuten diese leute quasi ja wenn du die meinst
Ja für diese natürlich blöd
Wenn das einzige was sie machen ist die leute offline im büro zu nerven mit irgendwelchen komischen dingern
Und das klappt dann im home office nicht mehr aber
Die sache ist die dass es auch die aufgabe des management dafür zu sorgen
Dass sowas eben ordentlich gehandelt wird und ein gutes beispiel wo man sehen kann dass es auch
Bei großen nicht funktioniert ist battlefield 2042
Das hat das bis zum schluss und auch das management hat es bis zum schluss nicht auf die reihe bekommen
Die leute ordentlich zu managen so dass sie im home office gescheit arbeiten können das ist nicht die schuld der mitarbeiter
die dort programmieren
Und in der art abteilung sind oder sonst was bei dem spiel machen das ist einzeln die schuld
Der management ebene dass sie das nicht hinbekommen haben
Das muss man sich mal überlegen dafür sind die mit verantwortlich dafür sind die da
Das ist ihre daseinsberechtigung so was zu koordinieren und zu planen
Und wenn die hören dass zwei drittel der leute drei stunden am tag
Brauchen bevor sie arbeiten anfangen können zu arbeiten weil irgendwas im bildprozess nicht richtig funktioniert
Dann ist es nicht ihre aufgabe zu sagen hey
Ich persönlich optimiere den bildprozess aber es ist ihre aufgabe zu sagen
Die richtigen leute an einen tisch zu bringen dass der bildprozess optimiert wird oder in irgendeiner anderen lösung gefunden wird dass das funktioniert
Und da muss im zweifelsfall der chef auch mal ein bisschen außerhalb der klassischen sachen denken wie man das machen könnte
Von ich gehe in saturn
Und bestell dort 500 konsole und schicke jedem einer daheim dass sie es testen können
Oder irgendwelche anderen dinger keine ahnung gibt es tatsächlich möglichkeiten aber das ist aufgabe des managements dafür sind die da
Gerade von gerade projekt manager
Das müssen die machen und das hat in battlefield 2042 nicht funktioniert da sieht man auch auch bei den ganz großen geht das oftmals in die hohre
Ich bin in saturn und bestell dort 500 konsole und schicke jedem einer daheim dass sie es testen können
Oder von gerade projekt manager
Und bestell dort 500 konsole und schicke jedem einen daheim dass sie es testen können
Wenn alle quasi das gleiche Ziel verfolgen, das hat man oft genug gesehen, vergleicht
alte Blizzard Spiele mit neuen.
Wenn die Leute nicht an einem Strang ziehen, klappt das nicht.
Mag sicherlich auch Gegenbeispiele geben.
Aber wenn du einen Großteil deines Tages mit internen Grabenkämpfen verbringst, dann
kommt meistens kein gutes Produkt bei raus.
Und eines der Hauptideen hinter dieser ganzen Agilitätsgeschichte ist ja, dass Entwickler
und Techniker und Manager sich weniger abfacken gegenseitig.
Dass Manager nach wie vor noch Steuerungsmöglichkeiten haben, aber die Techniker und Entwickler trotzdem
ihre Ruhe ungescheit arbeiten können, sodass ein qualitativ hochwertiger Unterbau entstehen
kann.
Ich habe aber auch überhaupt keinen Bock drauf.
Und was gabs zu futtern?
Ja, das ist natürlich auch nicht gut, wenn der Kollege, wenn er wirklich krank ist, trotzdem
auf die Arbeit kommt.
Ist auch richtig so, genau so denke ich mir das auch.
Das hat doch überhaupt keinen Sinn, du musst die Leute doch gar nicht kontrollieren.
Also nicht taktäglich.
Natürlich musst du insgesamt schon ein bisschen Überblick machen, ob da einer was macht
oder nicht.
Aber wenn du weißt, der erledigt das, was er erledigen soll, ist doch alles in Ordnung.
Wie der das macht, ob der nebenbei Netflix guckt oder nicht, ist doch vollkommen egal.
Ja, ich glaube, dass gerade bei Führungskräften auch mehr oder weniger so der Generationswechsel
langsam aber sicher vollzogen wird, klar, du hast noch richtig viele Oldschool Leute,
aber das wird immer weiter aufgeweicht, jetzt schon noch immer weiter abgelöst.
Das sehe ich zum Beispiel auch bei uns.
Wir haben zum größten Teil so super Oldschool Leute, auch alte Leute, aber wir haben jetzt
einen, also Vorstand weiß ich nicht, haben wir einen oder nicht Vorstand auf so Abteilungsleiter
Ebene.
Wir haben da jetzt einen, der ist zwar nicht Zoomer, aber das ist ungefähr mein Alter
und der sieht so Sachen wie Remote-Arbeiten, Homeoffice oder generell wie Projekte gehandelt
werden sollen auch wieder komplett anders.
Also auch Boomer, also wenn ich schon Boomer bin, was sind dann dann die restlichen Leute
da bei uns in der Führungsebene?
Gibt es noch sowas wie 60-jährige Boomer?
Ich kann es dir nicht genau sagen, aber wie gesagt, ich glaube der Fall war, da hat sich
das Bein gebrochen auf dem Weg vom Schlafzimmer ins Arbeitszimmer und es wurde am Ende entschieden,
es war ein Arbeitsunfall, aber die Details müsste man sich angucken, dann ist es vielleicht
nachvollziehbarer, habe ich nicht.
Wir können doch mal kurz gucken.
Gericht, Arbeitsunfall, kann doch nicht lange her gewesen sein.
Homeoffice, Sturz im Homeoffice zählt als Arbeitsunfall, ja ja, gilt der Unfallschutz,
wenn man im Homeoffice stürzt, ok, bla bla bla bla, die Wege sind nicht weit, trotzdem
kann es passieren, dass Zwischenbett und Schreibtisch ein Unglück passiert, ist ein Beschäftiger
dann auch gesichert.
Hier, im aktuellen Fall klagte ein Mann aus dem Raum Aachen, der als Angestellter Gebietsverkauf
sah, der im Aussehen zählte, er ist daher viel unterwegs, Verwaltungsaufgaben erledigt
er zu Hause, dort hat er sich hierfür ein Büro oberhalb der Wohnräume eingerichtet,
das über eine Wendeltreppe erreicht ist, ah das war eine Treppe gefallen, ok, im September
2008 stürzte er auf dem Weg von den Wohnräumen ins Homeoffice die Wendeltreppe hinunter,
dabei erlitt er einen Brustwirbeltrüpp, Alter, MonkaS, Alter, seine Ehefrau fand ihm, boah,
den hat er aber richtig zerfetzt, nicht einfach nur Bein gebrochen, Alter, na gut so ne Wendeltreppe
runter.
So, weil er auf direktem Weg zur Arbeit war, beantragte er bei einer berufsgeräten Handel
und wahren Logistik, die Anerkennung des Sturzes als Arbeitsunfall, die lehnte er jedoch ab
und dann hat er so verklagt, so, das Sozialgericht auch hat die Klage abgewiesen, Wege sind nicht
unfallversichert, haben die in erster Instanz gesagt, so, das Bundessozialgericht hat jetzt
aber gesagt, ist doch so, ja, wisst ihr, also, wenn er auf dem Weg vom Bett an den Schreibtisch
aufs Maul fällt, aufs Maul fällst und schlägst dir den Zahn aus, ist das ein Arbeitsunfall.
Usa, Dankeschön für den Sub, das haben wir doch grad schon, lull.
Tja, Pech gehabt, ne?
Ernsthaft, wirklich?
Ich seh da jetzt nix.
Fuck, die sind wirklich an der Goldgrube 12, geil, na passt ja.
Ja, die meisterfreundlich bestimmt.
Max, was ist deine Meinung zu Tech Stacks in deutschen Unternehmen, sind wir up to date
oder eher mehr, boah, das kommt ganz, das kannst du glaub ich nicht pauschal sagen, zumal man
ja auch nicht den Superpleading Edge Tech Stack verwenden muss, um gute Anwendung zu
machen.
Man kann bestimmt eine Super-Web-Dienstleistung anbieten auch mit PHP im Backend, das muss
kein React-Native-Mobile-Dings mit CraftQL und Azure Functions und was auch immer hyper
angesagtes Zeug ist sein.
Ich denke, es ist manchmal gar nicht so verkehrt, auch mal dran zu denken, vielleicht macht
man was nicht in der Super-Hype-Sprache mit dem Super-Hype-Framework, sondern irgendwas
bewerten, wo man Leute hat, die sich da langjährig mit auskennen.
Natürlich mit AI und Blockchain, klar.
Also zum Beispiel, wenn ich jetzt irgendwie ein Team habe, was die letzten Jahre über
hauptsächlich Java programmiert hat, warum sollte ich dann sagen, hey, wir machen jetzt
irgendwas super mega gehyptes für unsere neue Anwendung, anstatt es einfach Java zu
nehmen.
Macht ja keinen Sinn.
Letztendlich nimmt sich das meiste ja eh nicht so viel und ich denke vor allem, dass
man gucken muss, was für das Problem angemessen ist.
Ja, das ist jetzt in Zukunft eine
halide Antwort.
Also wenn einer jetzt daheim aufs Maul fällt, morgens kann er sagen, ich war gerade auf
dem Weg zum Rechner.
Auf der anderen Seite, so einfach ist es dann aber auch wiederum nicht, weil das muss dann
halt auch wirklich zu einer Zeit sein, das muss zu einem Arbeitstag sein, das muss zu
einer Zeit sein, wo du eh für gewöhnlich anfängst zu arbeiten.
Also wenn du jetzt sagen wir mal jeden Tag 37 dich am Rechner einloggst und auf einmal
um 11 sagst, ich bin aufgestanden, hatte einen Arbeitsumfall, also Rechner willst du vielleicht,
na gut, du kannst immer noch sagen, ich bin aufs Klo gegangen.
Jobdescription, whole stack developers will be required to see, was to see out a project
from conception, conception to final product requiring, das ist doch toll oder, das ist
doch toll, das ist aber noch falsch geschrieben alles, working experience 5-6 Jahre, whole
stack developer responsibilities, also webarchitektur, designing, aktuell applying pixel perfect
implementation of our approved user interface alles klar, server databases, speed scalability,
decree, das ist 100 pro troll, ach das ist auch programmer humor, sag doch mal einer
was das für ein subreddit ist, hab ich jetzt gar nicht gesehen, ja, aber wisst ihr was,
das ist nicht so weit weg von dieser stellenanzeige, die ich euch ja letztens gezeigt habe, das
ist nicht so weit weg von der hier, das sollst du auch alles machen, ja gut php vanilla,
wie gesagt ich sag ja, man soll was nehmen, was technologisch angemessen ist für das,
was man machen will und am besten wo man ahnung davon hat, jetzt ein eigenes cms auf vanilla
php basis bauen ist vielleicht nicht so die beste technologische entscheidung, aber der
fairness halber muss man sagen, das muss nicht zwangsläufig an php liegen, das kann auch
einfach an der unfähigkeit des unternehmens da liegen, dass sie das mit jeder x beliebigen
anderen sprache auch nicht richtig hin bekommen hätten, ich weiß nicht mal wer das ist,
ich hab keine ahnung wer das ist und warum er gedisst wird, ja das kommt mir bekannt
vor, das hab ich glaub ich gelesen, ah ja die i-message genau, das ist diese geschichte,
dass du an iphone übernehmen, also korrigier mich wenn ich falsch liege, das ist diese
geschichte, dass du an iphone übernehmen kannst, indem du die manipulierte i-message schickst,
ohne dass diese i-message überhaupt geöffnet werden muss, ja das ist richtig krass, die
haben eben ne vm gebaut und sind dann wieder ausgebrochen aus der vm, richtig massive big
sprain shit hier, oh ne, please don't do this to me, please don't do this to me, please
nicht wieder die diskussion, why are so many coders, ich finde das wort coders irgendwie
immer paintchamp, still using vim und emacs, ganz einfach ich kann euch sagen warum ich
vim verwende, ich verwende vim nicht um irgendwelche großartigen projekte von anfang bis ende
zu programmieren, sondern für kleine editier sachen wo ich direkt im terminal bleiben
will und natürlich auch über ssh, selbstverständlich verwende ich da vim und kein emacs, emacs
habe ich mal ne weile vor was weiß ich 5-6 jahren verwendet aber nie hauptsächlich und
auch eher zum rumbasteln, aber bin ich nie riesig warm damit geworden, zumal lisp wirklich
nicht zu meinen lieblingssprachen gehört, der post wurde von konsultants geschrieben,
weil, achso weil es an der realität vorbeigeht ja das kann schon sein, notepad plus plus,
gibt es notepad minus minus, ne, habe ich mir auch schon überlegt ob wir vielleicht
irgendwie, es gibt ja noch mehrere challenges, ich bin da aber nicht wirklich geübt drin,
wahrscheinlich kacke ich voll ab, vim als main ide, je nach sprache funktioniert
das auch, also gerade wenn es irgendwelches javascript oder python zeug ist, wo es schöne
plugins gibt, geht das, wobei ich ganz ehrlich, ich hab auch ne ganze zeit lang mein vim aufgebohrt
mit package managern und such plugins und sprachen addends und autocomplete geschichten
und so, es ist aber einfach nur pains champ, zumal wenn man wirklich die ide funktion haben
will und vim editing verwenden will, dann ist das wahrscheinlich besser, sagen wir jetzt
irgendwie mal keine ahnung rider oder intelligent zu verwenden und darin das jeweilige vim plugin
spacemax hatte ich auch mal ne weile ausprobiert, das war so magic, weil da war alles mögliche
drin, jaja genau die verwenden evil mode, also evil mode ist quasi in emacs der vim emulator,
der beste quasi der beste vim, der nicht vim ist, ist in emacs, aber die meisten leute
verwenden halt vielleicht 30 prozent von den vim shortcuts und von dieser vim editier language
und dann ist es besser, man verwendet seine ide seiner wahl, wenn man dann beispielsweise
java, c-sharp oder sonst was machen will mit nem vim plugin, wenn man dieses editing mag,
ich mag das vim editing auch, allerdings verwende ich es zum größten teil halt für ssh und
auf der konsole nicht jetzt irgendwie für ssharp oder sowas, ja es ist auch wild, wirklich
wild, also vim generell, also einem zugucken, der wirklich auch diese ganzen vim shortcuts
verwenden, sind ja nicht shortcuts, vim ist ja eher so ne sprache zum editieren, wo du
dann zum beispiel sagst, keine ahnung, ci anführungszeichen, was dann change inner quotes ist und sowas,
das ist wirklich maximal hacker man, ja, microsoft rolls out notepad with dark mode for windows,
insiders das bedeutet wir warten bis herbst bis wirs bekommen, na super, ich kenn das,
ja kenne ich, achso, ne das kenne ich noch nicht, bei mir ist es andersrum, wenn ich
e auf der konsole bin, am ehest noch mit ssh, dann mag ich das, wenn ich die vim bedienung
hab von text dateien oder für configs oder sowas, aber wenn ich beispielsweise irgendeine
spd or net anwendung bastel in rider zum beispiel, dann klicke ich auch mit der maus, und wisst
ihr warum ich mit der maus klicke, oder warum ich mich da eher daran gewöhnen kann, oder
lieber mit der maus klicke, weil ich dort hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt bin, nicht
permanent hacker man zu machen, sondern eigentlich hauptsächlich damit beschäftigt bin zu überlegen,
was ich jetzt eigentlich mache und was ich als nächstes mache, oder ob das sinnvoll
ist was ich da gerade mache, oder aber auf dem zweiten desktop im browser zu gucken,
und im browser brauchst du eh deine maus, ich weiß es gibt super krasse mega hacker
mans, die ihren browser auch mit tastatur bedienen, aber maus ist einfach wie gemacht
für den browser, so jetzt habe ich den chat endlich durch, aber ich gehe noch nicht,
ne keine sorge, ich hau noch nicht ab, erste 30 min betke, du guckst den stream über curl,
ja ich hoffe mit, ne nicht über curl, du musst das vlc mit ascii rendering gucken,
moment kann vlc, das muss ich mal kurz ausblenden, kann vlc twitch streams mittlerweile wieder
abspielen, geht das, testen wir mal, kann vlc das mittler, also vlc konnte das glaube
ich mal, vor ein paar versionen und mit anderer twitch api noch, das sieht nicht gut aus,
das sieht nicht gut aus, ja mpv kanns, aber mpv habe ich keine ahnung ob mpv ascii rendern
mpv, doch nice, mpv kanns, wir gucken jetzt meinen stream in ascii leute, passt auf, yes
pass auf gleich gehts los, was, habe ich quotes vergessen, ne das ist eigentlich egal ob ich
das quote, ich muss, ich muss kaka noch installieren glaube ich oder, muss ich kaka noch installieren,
ne ist installiert, kein kaka mehr, ah mpv hat scheinbar nichts, kein kaka support leute,
kaka fehlt, wie kann man das, ne was macht der hier, minus minus vo help
mein mpv hat kein lip kaka support, m player, m player, ey irgendwas werde ich doch hinbekommen,
m player, erstmal kurz gucken ob m player twitch auch spielen kann, kann das mpv überhaupt,
commercial break in progress, mhm, mhm, ok kaka, mpv, dann installieren wir jetzt mpv
mit kaka support, yes, jaja alles importieren kein problem, wir kompilieren das mal schnell
selbst, by the way archlinux, archlinux by the way, so hacker man time, obvious ich hoffe
ihr versteht alles was passiert, chat seid ihr schon drin, remove, yes, yes, yes, kaka,
ja, mh, Leute wir gucken twitch in ascii, das ist die twitch werbeunterbrechung, ah
yes, wir müssen aber was anderes gucken, weil wir sehen jetzt gleich ascii in ascii
gerendert wir müssen anderen stream auf machen sonst funktioniert das nicht zeig mal her
welch tv programming ne wie heißt das leute pool pool stream wir gucken uns jetzt pool stream in
ascii an gibt es in pools hat jemand coolen pool stream zur hand hot hot tube tup nicht hot hot
alles klar so das gucken wir uns jetzt in ascii an
so siehts aus hot hot tube in ascii und ihr erkennt was ihr erkennt was sagt nicht dass ihr
nix erkennt da ist ein bein und da sitzt hier jemand man erkennt das
ok jetzt habe ich zerstört das so nicht
man erkennt das leute hier sitzt jemand und bewegt irgendwie die die füße und beine
siehst du jetzt haben wir jetzt haben wir twitch in ascii am start darauf
jetzt hat sie sich rüber gebeugt wir gucken uns den ascii an so muss das sein
jetzt liest auch endlich was soll ich denn da lesen was soll das sein ich habe keine ahnung
was das sein soll aus dass jede menge katzen drin sind ach so die schriftgröße sehr klein
und neu starten ok guck mal hier mehr pixel leute ascii axi hot ascii hot tube jetzt erkennt man
richtig gut was oder booba aber muss sagen es funktioniert ja also es
gibt leute die durchaus twitch auf ascii gucken könnten
ich habe jetzt einfach die erste pool streamerin die ich gefunden habe aufgemacht also das
funktioniert das wird auch durch den ssh tunnel ganz gut funktionieren das braucht ja kaum
bandbreite wollen wir mal gucken wie viel bandbreite das braucht seck wir gucken noch
mal schon schnell wie viel bandbreite das braucht ihr seht jetzt nicht was ich schreibe aber ihr
werdet gleich bandbreite erkennen guck mal das braucht nix das braucht achthundert
kibi kibi kibi kibi kibi kibi pro sekunde also knapp knapp ein m bit braucht das knapp
ein m bit das ist nicht viel als kriegst du auch über ssh verbindung rüber also leute
das wisst ihr bescheid ich kann nicht mehr abbrechen es ist broken kill all mpv so wieder
runter geschmissen es wird sogar über nullmode im kabel ne das funktioniert nicht das sind
ja 9600 bytes das funktioniert nicht das wird auch funktionieren klar warum nicht ich bin
mir nicht so sicher ob sie das als als geeignet sponsoring thema sehen würden how to watch
a hot tube streams offer ssh help of hetzer cloud das glaube ich nicht so das gute placement
ich kann es euch jetzt nicht zeigen aber ich habe gerade in meine mails geguckt weil ich
habe heute an hetzer die rechnung geschrieben für die streams und videos dieses jahr und
ich habe gerade meine mails reingeguckt ob da irgendwie zufällig eine antwort kam wenn
es 24 nun wahrscheinlich aber ich habe eine spam mail bis spam meldung bekommen gerade
auf meine private email adresse santa ist riding mal dick da stand quasi santa ist riding
oder unten drunter mein dick was du bescheuern kutschi base alter santa ist riding könnte
ich also jede x beliebige weihnachtsgrüße meld sein aber wenn mein dick noch drunter
kommt dann ist das aber ich schaue noch mal kurz rein von wem der welcher absender welcher
absender das überhaupt ist was kalt wissen wir wissen wir der absender ist da ist ein
vacuum der staubsauger hersteller ist angeblich der absender ist angeblich der absender das
ist ja mal da hat wahrscheinlich irgendwie einer so einen spam baukasten genommen und
einfach mal zusammengeklickt da ist ein vacuum jetzt müssen wir noch gucken über welchen
server das verschickt wurde wahrscheinlich irgendwie gekommnet punkt ru beidstrang nicht
keine ahnung was hat er denn geguckt ich würde sagen dazu mal eine sache gachi roll gachi
roll leute ach gedruckt keine ahnung was hat er denn gedruckt
oh man ja super im herbst kriegt windows jetzt auch ein dark mode
da hat er die welt drauf gewartet
gibt es eigentlich ich will jetzt nicht ins door gucken
gibt es eigentlich im window store
mittlerweile original studio code wahrscheinlich nicht oder
also ich habe einen wlan weihnachtsbaum einen wlan weihnachtsbaum
moment das ist doch keine lampe was er da druckt oder das sieht schon ein bisschen nach
gachi bass aus
wo sieht man das fertige sus sieht so aus ja aber auch das rpg nicht das rpg dass das
rgb game durchgespielt oder
boah leute ich bin immer noch so voll gefressen ganz schlimm ganz schlimm ich sag euch
jetzt noch nachtisch boah
fleischbällchen das finde ich interessant dass du fleischbällchen gefuddelt hast wir
haben auch bestimmt 10 15 jahre lang an weihnachten fleischbällchen gefuddelt
aber machen das jetzt schon eine weile nicht mehr haben wirklich lange gemacht
was ist eigentlich aus dem amazon plan geworden
jetzt drohnen zu den leuten heim zu schicken gibt es da schon irgendwelche tests und ist
damit zu rechnen dass das irgendwann tatsächlich mal kommen wird
ich meine ich stelle es mir in deutschland besonders schwierig vor wir sind ja relativ
also nicht so wie in australien wo du dann irgendwie 15 kilometer erst mal über das
nichts fliegst wir sind ja schon relativ dicht besiedelt und wir haben ja auch viele
technikfeindliche leute die die drohnen dann auch irgendwie rund ja ja hätten wir auch
wir hätten garantiert auch leute die die drohnen abschießen würden
vielleicht nicht wie bei den amis mit irgendeiner zielsuchenden rakete oder so wer weiß was
so der durchschnitts durchschnitts kikona in seinem hinterhof hat anti air gun aber mit
irgendeiner armbrust oder irgendwie so einem irgendwelchen legal zu erwärmenden dinge
hätten wir auch leute die die drohnen abgeschossen hätten aber ich fände es halt geil
wisst ihr ich fände es wirklich cool wenn man heute was bestellen kann bei amazon und
es ist einfach in eineinhalb stunden da da was ein wort alle da es wäre einfach in eineinhalb
stunden da das wäre doch geil der einzige grund warum ich sehr selten noch in leden
gehe um dort irgendwas zu kaufen also jetzt haben wir so technik und sowas ist weil ich
gleich brauche doch da ist schwedisch ja klingt auch irgendwie schwedisch da ja das
ist gekommodert norm oder kde tja wenn du mich fragst i3 aber wenn ich mir aussuchen
müsste vor das ist als wäre das ist ja zwischen wie und pest und cholera wählen dann wahrscheinlich
gnome lieber gnome wobei ich halt alles was mit gnome zusammenhängt nicht mag zum beispiel
das gtk so verhunzt ist mittlerweile oder schon immer war gtk war von der idee her
ich war ein relativ sinniges cross platform gui framework aber die machen das laufen kaputt
für alles andere außer gnome und habt ihr mal versucht gtk unter windows zu verwenden
können knicken kein wunder dass jeder also es geht aber aber wie kein wunder dass sie
alle umgestiegen sind vlc ist umgestiegen wire shark ist umgestiegen ich glaube alle
auf auf cute ne t plus plus ist allein schon das genug abschreckung also von der technik
her eindeutig kde aber ich finde kde software so unglaublich unübersichtlich und leinteilig
gar nicht mal so sehr weil die viele optionen hat eigentlich müsste es mir gefallen software
zu haben mit vielen optionen aber ich finde in kde ist es dann ist es dann halt unübersichtlich
im implementiert die optionen ist ja gut aber viele optionen einfach nur untereinander geklatscht
in riesen settings menü nicht also keine ahnung also ich bin kein fan weder von gnome
noch von kde ich mag mal die drei und ich benutze zum größten teil auch keine gtk oder
keine cute kde anwendung ich benutze eh kaum was ich benutze mein gnome terminal ja das
ist eine gtk anwendung ja ich weiß aber ich mein naja da ist von gtk jetzt im ende viel
zu sehen ich benutze mein terminal und ich benutze einen browser und dann benutze ich
hier drauf entweder visual studio code oder ein paar idees fertig ich benutze so gut wie
nichts irgendwie an großartig zusätzlicher software ich mache nahezu alles was irgendwie
hier geht so management technik übers technisch übers terminal und der rest ist ja eigentlich
nur progas zeug und da brauche ich hauptsächlich den browser für und per editors gnome terminal
ist end of life wirklich wie das ist end of life was soll denn jetzt kommen wie kommst
da drauf das ist doch jebait oder
other side das wäre auch nicht so schlimm ich meine es gibt mittlerweile
3000 andere terminals muss ja nicht grad eins in elektron sein ja wie ich weiß nicht ob
ich einen zusätzlichen browser offen haben will im hintergrund nur für mein terminal
gibt es sowas wie einen endloses l
das ist das ist der kappa pride train
kann man eigentlich das ascii aquarium auch lollketten ah yes
auch besser so ist es doch nice so mag ich das
der dafisch ins bett ich bin aber noch nicht müde aber ich weiß nicht mehr was ich euch
noch erzählen soll und außerdem habe ich so viel pippo fett gemacht ich müsste glaube
ich schon mal aufs klo demnächst popo s cosmetic rust
rust based desktop
könnt ihr das nicht in der programmiersprache machen die man versteht ohne expanded brain
auf dotnet basis wäre zum beispiel was dann würde ich auch kapieren so lange es nicht
in elektron ist und java script bin ich ja froh schon mal
meinetwegen sogar in go ich mein rust ist schon ok
dann haben wir das gleiche problem wie elementary und sowas dass sie halt wieder keine anwendung
gescheit dafür haben und unter der haube brauchen die leute dann eh wieder gtk gnome
und und cute kde anwendung also mit einheitlichem look and feel ist da eh nix weil die werden
doch garantiert nicht anfangen jetzt dort eine gute notiz ab einen guten text editor
einen guten musik player einen guten browser und so zu implementieren da kommt ein chrome
drauf die machen das auch mit gtk oder was ok dann werden die viel spaß haben weil
die gtk leute machen alle furz lang war was kaputt
mal gucken sollen sie mal machen das ist eines der gründe warum nie das ja des linux desktops
wird weil das was es gibt ist krepp uns ja keine ahnung wirklich mal einmal mit vision
hat er nicht genug leute ach keine ahnung ist mir aber auch egal weil das was ich linux
mäßig auf dem desktop verwende ist so minimalistisch ich brauch den ganzen kram nicht
moin leiko moin fadlitz sind alle am start auch alle pepo fett gefressen jetzt
watschi bait ne ne da bin ich nein nein wer soll das denn sein max mps hört sich an
wie so ein so ein bremssystem für autos
ja leute ich würde sagen es ist tatsächlich bettgetime ich habe auch nichts mehr jetzt
für den stream großartig mir überlegt ich bin einfach angekommen und habe jetzt zweieinhalb
stunden mit euch geschwätzt outro musik ok sekunde outro musik youtube
ich will das original haben kein remix kein remix kein remix das da excellent
also leute wir sehen uns bis dann machts gut